-Performing the title track
from their new album,
"Glorious Game,"
give it up for Black Thought
and El Michels Affair,
featuring Kirby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Okay, I'm too Black
for y'all to erase ♪
♪ Shoot too straight
for y'all to retrace ♪
♪ Too abstract
for y'all to replace ♪
♪ You all would be safe
but y'all are deep fake ♪
♪ Too fake for me
to waste time ♪
♪ Too two-faced
for me to say fine ♪
♪ I'm the one-man army, Ason ♪
♪ The baseline is
we just ain't the same kind ♪
♪ Gloves and mask off,
time to blast off ♪
♪ Baton I'll pass off,
rhyme your ass off ♪
♪ If we clash,
I'll haul the trash off ♪
♪ I'll haul the cash off
and ball in Nassau ♪
♪ That's all,
it ain't too much talk ♪
♪ All y'all chumps,
it ain't enough chalk ♪
♪ Y'all thought the name
was just Thought? ♪
♪ Come on, I'm too strong
for y'all to cut short ♪
♪ You see light like mine
once a lifetime ♪
♪ When some young chump
becomes an icon ♪
♪ But somehow they'll cut down
the flight time ♪
♪ Unless you puts that heat
down the pipeline ♪
♪ My mind is hard to explain ♪
♪ Call y'all all aboard
for this train ♪
♪ I float like
a nautilus, mane ♪
♪ Damn, I love
this glorious game ♪
-♪ Hey, pimpin'
ain't dead, baby ♪
♪ Mackin' ain't dead, baby,
I swear ♪
♪ These are the glory days ♪
-Swear to God.
-♪ Pimpin' ain't dead, baby ♪
♪ Mackin' ain't dead, baby,
I swear ♪
♪ These are the glory days ♪
-Talk to 'em.
-♪ I might take my fur off
and walk like ish, baby ♪
♪ I might put my game on
and take your chick, baby ♪
♪ I might put my fur on
and talk my ish, baby ♪
♪ I might put my game on
and take your chick ♪
-♪ Okay, I'm proof that
we all should get free ♪
♪ Direct from the streets
of S.P. ♪
♪ Who alone tryna be
the next thing? ♪
♪ For real, I'm just tryna
be the best me, so ♪
♪ No gas, I'm high in octane ♪
♪ Which icon am I
if not flames? ♪
♪ Aw, damn it,
guess who not lame ♪
♪ And locked the block down
before the blockchain ♪
♪ Stop playin',
the stakes is too high ♪
♪ Some say life's a bitch,
then you die ♪
♪ Patience brings all things
in due time ♪
♪ If you's a real one,
well, that's a true sign ♪
♪ My time the valuable kind ♪
♪ Take these words
to rendezvous by ♪
♪ I drop psychological lines ♪
♪ Y'all style
on the comical side ♪
♪ Seekers, keep this close
to your chest ♪
♪ Weakness killed this culture,
more or less ♪
♪ Y'all project
such a snorefest ♪
♪ No paycheck,
just exit stage left ♪
♪ My mind is hard to explain ♪
♪ I contain
one marvelous brain ♪
♪ Call y'all all aboard
for this train ♪
♪ Damn, I love
this glorious game ♪
-♪ Hey, pimpin'
ain't dead, baby ♪
♪ Mackin' ain't dead, baby,
I swear ♪
♪ These are the glory days ♪
-Swear to God.
-♪ Pimpin' ain't dead, baby ♪
♪ Mackin' ain't dead, baby,
I swear ♪
♪ These are the glory days ♪
-Talk to 'em.
-♪ I might put my fur on
and talk my ish, baby ♪
♪ I might put my game on
and take your chick, baby ♪
-Talk to 'em, Kirby.
-♪ I might put my fur on
and talk my ish, baby ♪
♪ I might put my game on
and take your chick ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
♪ Hey, these are
the glory days ♪
♪ These are the glory days ♪
♪ These are the glory days,
I swear ♪
♪ These are the glory days ♪
-Get up.
♪♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ These are the glory days ♪
♪ These are the glory, ha ♪
♪ These are the glory, hey ♪
♪ These are
the glory days, baby ♪
♪ These are the glory days ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh. Thank you, bud.
Thank you, man.
-That's the way to do it.
-That's how --
Fantastic.
That's how you do it
right there. Come on.
Black Thought,
El Michels Affair, Kirby!
"Glorious Game" is out now.